[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao papo na arena se o
podcast semanal onde a gente indica troc
sobre conteúdos que a gente L ouv ass
sempre trazendo visão de produto para
discussão eu sou Artur eu preciso contar
PR vocês que eu vou ser
pai o segredo que a gente
vinha os dois episódios né Parabéns meu
amigo você seja muito feliz que venha
com
saúde tudo tudo de bom e depois dessa
notícia eu sou a x né não tem nem o que
dizer só comemorar só Celebrar e no
programa de hoje que é edição número 40
né ou ver Redonda é redondo a gente vai
falar dos anúncios da
wwdc conferência da Apple é isso mas
antes da gente falar disso aí tem jabex
sempre né inclusive vai ter né como
sempre o o Jabá ele vai ser
contextualizado porque vai ter o curso
de ai para PMs que vai ser online ao
vivo comigo e com efren no dia 20 de
julho E ai que é um tópico que a gente
vai falar logo daqui a pouco do Apple
intelligence exato E além disso tem o
curso de pensamento crítico analítico
com o Dudu e comigo dia 29/06 vai ser
online ao vivo e dia 6 de julho vai ser
presencial aqui em São Paulo o link tá
na descrição com aquele descontinho
Maroto Bora lá PR paa Então bora
[Música]
lá então
segunda-feira rolou mais uma edição da
wwdc que é a worldwide
Dev e a gente vai falar dos principais
anúncios mas já deixar a dica a
conferênci São vários dias né a gente
vai falar aqui dos da principal da kde
né no Dia Inicial mas já fica a dica
aqui que tem muitas sessões q&a e várias
coisas várias dicas e tudo mais no
próprio site da APP é só você acessar
developer.apple.com wwdc
24 e você vai poder ver as todas as
sessões que eles fazem lá tem muito
conteúdo Bacana Então recomendo aí para
quem trabalha com produto não é só
apesar de ser uma conferência para
desenvolvedores recomendo bastante
porque tem muitas coisas lá e muitos
exemplos de como utilizar as tecnologias
e tudo mais eu ia falar isso acho que a
coisa mais legal são os vários Como tem
muita coisa nova normalmente que eles
introduzem eles trazem melhores práticas
exemplos então é uma boa fonte de
inspiração né tipo tanto para apps que
você trabalha que possam se aproveitar
disso quanto referência geral né a Apple
é referência de design de experiência
então sempre bom ter ter esse tipo de
conteúdo disponível é isso e um dado
interessante aqui só no YouTube a gente
tá gravando na segunda-feira que no dia
que rolou a conferência aqui já tem mais
de 5 milhões de
visualizações fácil né é bom ser Apple
né né mas com o que que a gente vai
começar ah não tem outra coisa a não ser
ai só que é lógico que a Apple ela ia
dar um jeito né ela ia dar um jeito de
de só para poder usar o mesmo a mesma
sigla né porque Apple inteligence é ai
né também exato exato não conseguem né
não conseguem é mas vamos lá acho que
fazendo um um overview aqui ela anunciou
coisas para alguns tópicos coisas para
escrita né coisas para imagens e teve as
coisas também pra Siri é e e acho que o
negócio interessante é que eles deram
esse branding de Apple intelligence e
dentro disso não tem só ai generativa né
Tem coisas que são ai generativa tem
coisas que são machine learning mais
tradicional então eles botaram e e em
outros momentos aqui note eles também
trouxeram aplicações de machine learning
fora desse branding de Apple
intelligence mas é onde estão as coisas
mais aí generativa de Fato né que a
gente vem vendo aí nos últimos meses que
a gente conversa para caramba aqui no
programa total e assim uma outra coisa
também nessa
WC a Apple matou mais uns vários apps né
quem quem mata mais app é open ai quando
atualiza o chat GPT ou a Apple né Pois é
uma boa disputa agora elas se
complementam né na verdade a Apple a
Apple usa open air de arma para matar os
aplicativos é mas vamos lá começando
pelas writing Tools cara Acho que a
primeira coisa lá que ela que eles
fizeram o lance de que eles anunciaram
né O lance de reescrever as frases os
textos né de uma forma mais friendly
mais mais profissional ou mais concisa
Dá para colocar o tldr lá também dá para
fazer o Sumário tudo isso dá para ajudar
Tipo na resposta tipo o quick reply lá
que eles anunciaram também acho que
todos os exemplos clássicos de uso do
chat GPT para texto Eles foram lá e
aplicaram dentro dos ambientes né E aí
dentro dos aplicativos tanto nativos
quanto não nativos né então tem o tem no
Notes e no mail que eu acho que foram os
exemplos municipais que eles deram mas a
princípio funciona no no os inteiro né e
eu acho que essa é a grande tônica do
que a Apple falou e eu acho que a gente
chegou a citar isso em algum dos
programas aqui que o grande Apple não ia
trazer isso como um produto standalone
né um chat GPT da Apple ela ia trazer
integrado ao os que é onde tá o grande
valor né e a gente se não lembro se a
gente conversou no privado se forando no
programa também é aquela parada de você
trazer pro dia a dia das pessoas
pro cidadão comum as ferramentas né
então você traz a tecnologia como
ferramenta e não como fim vamos dizer
assim da coisa é isso e com isso também
tipo várias coisas na parte de imagens
né de você poder desde adicionar coisas
numa alguma coisa que você tá escrevendo
então Adiciona uma imagem lá num texto e
tudo mais até o image playground lá que
é você poder ar as imagens adicionar as
coisas você retirar as coisas da foto
que o Google já já tava faz goog fotos
mandou abraço né exato mas agora também
e aí entra mais uma série de apps que a
Apple mata agora fazendo isso também é
no Google fotos eu não sei hoje né mas
pelo menos e quando eu comecei a usar
era exclusivo para quem assinava o
Google One né é tipo cara da Apple é
free para você que tá no aparelho você
tem o iPhone funciona então tipo de novo
de democratizar e espalhar a tecnologia
ali né Total também tem o o lance de da
generativo né que é a coisa de você
poder criar os Memories né que são os
videozinhos lá com as suas fotos e você
pode escrever Ah quero um vídeo com tal
tal tal coisa e ele monta baseado nas
suas fotos pode pedir PR Siri também né
É você pode pedir PR Siri tem o g emoji
também que é você poder fazer o seu
próprio emoji né baseado no nos emj já
existente é o memo verso é o memo verso
ess achea interessante act é e e também
teve as coisas relacionadas a Siri né
antes de entrar na Siri deixa só falar
de imagem porque eu acho que tem um
negócio interessante que eu li num texto
Inclusive essa semana eu deixo o link aí
pra galera que qual seria o take da
Apple sobre imagens e o texto que eu
falei ele pegava muito Qual é a
capacidade atual das Ferramentas de
geração de de imagem com com ai e fazia
uma previsão ali do que que a Apple
podia trazer e cara o cara foi
exatamente preciso de tipo a Apple não
vai deixar você fazer imagens realistas
ela vai botar que foi exatamente o que
ela fez ilustrações animações sket então
ela dá esses três estilos E aí muito
para o que esse texto fala até né pô com
isso você coíbe vários problemas ali por
exemplo de Deep fake Então você consegue
num aparelho que tá na mão de várias
pessoas as pessoas que tin um medo né de
como que isso num aparelho que é Popular
como que isso poderia aumentar o
problema de Deep fakes e coisas do tipo
e a Apple Falou cara não vai ser ó Isso
é para Ji é bom muito bom para fazer
isso daqui eu vou te dar essa constraint
que você consegue fazer só isso daqui tá
ligado Então é uma constraint por um
lado mas faz sentido por outro Sabe sim
sim bom indo pra pra Siri acho que bem
de linha do que que é o GPT anunciou né
H algumas semanas atrás é ah a conversa
mais natural a parte de memory né que é
ela Você pode perguntar e logo em
seguida perguntar alguma coisa que ela
vai pegar o contexto anterior o contexto
ah pessoal seu então eles dão até o
exemplo lá de Ah que hora que é o voo da
minha mãe o que que eu combinei com ela
de jantar E aí ele pô pega lá do im
message e do seu e-mail também que hora
que é o vo o que que você tinha
combinado e tudo mais e para mim assim
dessas coisas a mais novidade foi a
parte de você poder digitar também né
você poder falar o Type to Siri ao invés
de só falar com ela né é total e também
ela vai só para deixar claro né ela vai
usar o GPT 4 né inclusive ela pede
permissão ali é o for é quando precisa
bater lá e para dar um resultado melhor
né e acho que é negócio se vocês olharem
lá as redes sociais da galera da Open ai
falando Ah um prazer
Partner with Apple e tal para esses
lançamentos então de fato o negócio que
estavam que era um rumor até então né de
que a Apple iria usar a Open a como
parceira para as coisas de Ji é verdade
de fato estão usando e demos aqui em
primeira mão hein não era era um boato
espalhado né cara Artur você que é um
cara que está no mundo iOS há muito
tempo o quanto você usa Siri hoje e o
quanto você acha que você vai usar com
essas novas coisas cara eu vou falar que
eu uso bem pouco eu uso para coisas
muito simples tipo timer bem bem pouco
alarme é bem pouco mas eu acho que eu
vou usar um pouco mais cara porque eu já
uso bastante o GPT então agora com o
contexto pessoal E como eu tenho do tipo
exato literalmente o ecossistema inteiro
da Apple do relógio ao o iPad ao
computador ao iPhone Então eu acho que
agora eu vou usar muito mais tá ligado
não sei mas veremos é eu acho que essa é
a parada [__] um tá integrado ao sistema
operacional né então a gente não falou
aqui né mas tem toda a parte de Actions
que é você conseguir pedir para Siri
fazer ações ali Ah então ô cria uma um
tdo para mim no meu to doist de fazer
não sei o qu amanhã Então vão ter tanto
coisa dos first Party dos apps da Apple
quanto Third Party né obviamente
precisando de integração ali a gente não
falou também mas não é o Apple
intelligence ele vai tá entre devices né
então é iPhone iPad e Mac Então vai
existir ali em todos eles e eu acho que
na teoria é muito maneiro de Tipo pô
você pede para Sil fazer as coisas e ela
dentro do os consegue entender e ser uma
assistente na prática eu quero ver muito
isso sendo implementado por th pares
porque eu acho que vai ter muito valor
quando você integra com appp e tal eh e
eu quero ver porque eu acho que tem uma
complexidade técnica grande eles falam
de busca semântica e tal então eu fico
imaginando cara Vários apps tendo que
adicionar uma camada semântica que às
vezes eles não tinham para permitir que
o sistema buscas informações de forma
estruturada e sirva aquilo então pode
ser que eu quero ver se não vai ser só
muito muito bonito nos apps da Apple e
não tão funcional em apps de terceiros
ao mesmo tempo que eu não sei o quantos
usuários da Apple usam apps de terceiro
ou eles ficam presos ali no mundinho dos
apps e puros tipo eu conheço muito
usuário que é R user Tipo você mas será
que o usuário médio ele os caras usam
imessage né velho então eu fico
imaginando tipo cara se for muito [__]
Só no notas câmera fotos Apple music e
tal já vai ser o suficiente para boa
parte dos usuários Eu imagino Pois é
veremos é e acho que por último mas não
menos importante sobre isso eles falaram
muito de privacidade né acho que é a
coisa principal ali então a nível
arquitetural boa parte do processamento
vai ser feito no device O que significa
Muito provavelmente que eles estão
usando small language models então eles
estão usando llms ali mas de tamanho
menor né para fazer esse processamento e
eles Vão bater em servidores da própria
Apple mas servidores e chamam de private
Cloud computing onde não vai existir
armazenamento de informação ele vai lá
processa e volta quando necessário Então
acho que pra galera aí os bastiões da
privacidade cara boas notícias assim e
acho que todo mundo dizia isso também
que que a Apple olharia muito pra
privacidade e também até se você olhar
as features de privacidade do iOS 18 faz
muito sentido né serem anunciado juntos
sim e eu esqueci aqui a gente falou na
abertura aqui mas eu esqueci a coisa
mais legal que eu achei nessa
conferência como todo foi a abertura
porque foi os caras saltando de
paraquedas cara o Craig a galera S de
paraquedas cra federigo cara O cra não
dá ele é é mas assim eu fiquei feliz e
triste ao mesmo tempo né porque Pô legal
ver um monte de gente paraquedismo ali
mas triste por saber que eles não
estavam usando o meu App de paraquedismo
né que pô agora não não vai ter chance
teria timing né perfeito é pois é enfim
é vamos pras próximas coisas aí da w
vamos lá Vision os cara Apple lançou em
Fevereiro eu tava até olhando aqui foi
em fevereiro que a gente fez até um
episódio sobre isso e eu nem lembro mais
do Apple Vision pro velho é cara eu acho
que tem uns pontos interessantes aqui
não sobre o device o primeiro para mim é
é o Vision os 2.0 então eles fizeram um
um salto de diversão do os e veio rid qu
meses é isso que não é o normal tipo a
Apple no IOS é um por ano né basicamente
assim e me pareceu muito pouca coisa
para ser um salto de versão tipo para
mim era cara podia ser 1.5 1.3 ali sabe
me pareceu muito pouca coisa É porque no
final das contas Foi algumas coisas lá
para foto
mais coisa relacionada ao spatial Forums
lá mas assim não teve Nossa nenhuma
parada a coisa diferentinha para falar
os novos gestos é tem isso é né que tem
esse novo gesto lá para você ver tanto a
bateria quanto para você voltar pra home
e tudo mais pode parecer simples mas a
parte que eu gostei disso eu gostaria
que isso fosse pro Apple watch também a
gente já vai falar do watch os ali que
eles trouxeram mais coisas também mas eu
gostaria que outros gestos também fosse
assim pro Apple watch e vai na linha do
que a gente falou lá quando foi lançado
né No No ano passado no evento disso de
Será que eles vão colocar novos novos
gestos no no Apple watch e uma vez que
tá no Apple Vision Putz pode ser que
esteja também em breve no no Apple watch
também né é eh o que me chamou mais
atenção dele foi um a possibilidade de
no app de fotos você no FaceTime ali com
a outra pessoa que tem o Vision pro
vocês estarem olhando para as mesmas
coisas PR umas fotos que eu acho que é
um passo em direção você ter uma
experiência completa compartilhada que
eu acho que é um caminho que a Apple vai
e para quem tem Mac ele usa né Que deve
ser 100% da base do Vision pro é você
tem um maior display e resolução no na
na conexão ali com display isso eu acho
me parece um dos usos mais [__] assim
mais legais e eu acho super legal agora
tem Wide dá para você deixar o bit Wide
é e nessa linha aí eles também lançaram
as OS mod você no no avião ou no trem né
também que é agora é verdade caso de uso
é e eu acho que a última coisa assim
para mim eu acho que eles estão
teasing que esse produto vai caminhar
mais para uma linha de pros de fato e
menos de consumer porque teve uma parte
ali de professional workflows e coisas
assim que tipo tem lente Canon agora
para capturar spal víde Então não é mais
só no iPhone que você consegue você
consegue editar o Special víde no Final
Cut você consegue visualizar no Vimeo
que é um serviço de vídeo muito usado
por profissionais de e de vídeo e tal
fizeram toda uma parte de enterprise api
eh black Magic Design da vint resolve
Então vários aplicativos e até serviços
de hardware aí na empresas de hardware
que tão tendo integrações ou fazem
coisas ali com o visual pro Então para
mim isso também é um movimento ali na
linha de cara posicionar mais o Vision
pro como um aparelho para pros de Fato
né E outra parada também que você anotou
aqui mas eu vou falar cara é bizarro né
já tem vários meses que esse device foi
lançado e só tem 2000 apps específicos
né eles falam mais de 1 milhão e meio de
aplic Eu achei até muito eu eu anotei
aqui na minha lista porque eu falei 2000
específicos eu achei muito mano a pouco
pouco achei achei bastante coisa E aí
outra estratégia outro detalhe pequeno
mas vai muito em conta a estratégia que
eles vão lançar para novos países né
eles anunciaram isso e tem uma pequena
frase que fala ah a gente vai lançar
para alguns outros países e começando
com a China By The Way nos últimos
quarters nas quando a Apple divulgou os
resultados um dos maiores impactos dos
resultados não terem sido legais foram
por conta das vendas e dos problemas que
estavam rolando na China só que nos
últimos no último mês se não me engano
os os números voltaram a crescer foi na
última divulgação de resultados eles
fizeram um corte de preço na China e
voltaram a crescer exato E aí eles
fizeram uma super promoção lá e tal que
é uma coisa que a Apple não não costuma
fazer mas fizeram aumentou o share lá e
consequentemente melhorou os resultados
E aí lógico para fazer uma média já vão
lançar o Vision pro lá também né É É um
dos maiores mercados do mundo né De
qualquer forma Então se se tem um lugar
que pode pegar talvez e aumentar esse
número de vendas é para lá né E só para
registrar não tem Brasil nessa lista de
países onde o Vision pro vai ser lançado
oficialmente né que mais iOS o
queridinho cara o iOS eu me senti que
agora eu vou usar um Android isso para
mim o resumo da apresentação do IOS é
bem-vindo ao Android sei lá 10 11 sei lá
de andro qu anos atrás tá no 15 Eu Acho
É então exato bom Resumindo você pode
colocar seu ícone onde você quiser na
tela agora ô Yes tá zoando aqui mas teve
uma coisinha legal assim que eu acho que
eu acho que pro usuário do iOS que era
todo capado é legal não é legal tipo
tanto faz para quem não usa iOS eu eu
vejo ali e falo Bora é agora dá para
pintar todos os zeps da mesma cor é
agora é o Zap de tema que tem na Google
Play
botou isso no sistema é tem o Mas eles
fizeram também o redesign do aplicativo
de fotos né isso eu acho legal é ficou
achei que foi interessante e uma outra
coisa Eu particularmente uso muito assim
que é o o control center E aí eles
liberaram as coisas que quando lá atrás
Eles colocaram os atalhos e tudo mais
tinha muito essa dúvida né tipo cara pô
por que que não deixa o desenvolvedor
criar os atalhos ali também para ficar
mais fácil t pô é uma coisa simples e
que assim já bobear já deve ter no
Android mas eu achei pô prático e o que
eu achei melhor ainda foi o aspecto duas
coisas um você vai poder usar o Action
button para também fazer isso que a
gente até falou no ano passado também no
episódio pô quando que será que eles vão
liberar isso Será que vai demorar muito
tempo mas não eu acho que eles foram
rápidos que dava para fazer tipo work
around via shortcut né É mas eu acho que
eles foram rápidos assim histórico da
Apple é eu acho que eles foram rápidos
de liberar isso para pros developers
total para mim é a parada mais
interessante até do control center Esse
é então só para dar um contexto assim
para quem usa iOS também quando você dá
o arrasta a tela para baixo lá e aparece
ali a sua tela você tem lá você podia
colocar né lanterna notas Podia colocar
não estava lá e você não podia mexer
você podia mexer sim você podia
selecionar quais você queria adicionar
lá só que eram todos relacionados a a
levar esse a coisas da Apple né Agora se
o seu aplicativo tiver e eu já tô com
IOS 18 e aí eu te falo que já tem alguns
apps que Cadê já tem não deixa eu ver se
já tem algum app aqui no
iOS testando ó Real Time aqui ó eu
instalei mas eu não comecei a fuçar
ainda en enquanto Artur procura não tem
né Nenhum app meu ainda tem tá aqui mas
tem muito mais coisas agora é você pode
ter páginas de control center né então
uma página
tradicional uma uma página ali para
controle de mídia uma página para
controle da sua casa que é o exemplo que
o que o Craig dá e tal então é assim de
eu acho que melhorou a vida de quem usa
iOS não é algo absolutamente novo o que
por isso que o que eu achei legal é o
Action Button de fato você poder usar o
Action button para disparar as coisas
Porque de fato melhoria de vida ali não
precisa fazer shortcut pros negócios e
tal mas acho que era um negócio que já
tava bem resolvido algum tempo e a Apple
só Demorou PR fazer Tem mais alguma
coisa interessante de Ah tem o TT Cash
né você encostar o celularzinho e fazer
uma transferência lá pelo Apple Wallet
que eu acho que é um negócio mais pros
Estados Unidos que o Brasil o Brasil tem
o pix né velho eu tava até vendo os Car
americano mesmo falando cara o vemo dá
pr fazer isso isso e [__] fiz uma vez com
um celular perto do outro sabe então é Ô
mas nessa coisa de celular do T no
celular eu tenho usado muito o airdrop
fazendo ou encostando o Device no outro
sabe ao invés do tipo só aparecer o de
de enviar lá por quê sei lá por não
então porque muitas vezes demora para
aparecer o Ah tá porque é mais rápido
você fazer aí é mais fácil eu já vou lá
e pimba po lembrando do do finado Bump
lembra não Bump Pô o Bump o Google
comprou e matou ele depois mas era isso
você podia mandar foto mandar algumas
coisas você en encostava o Device no
outro Lógico que as duas pessoas tinham
que ter o b mas é carac cara putz é
muito tempo atrás mas enfim então eles
lançaram isso lá e lançaram algumas
coisas para game também né vai ter o
game mode lá é tem game mode agora que
também já tinha no Android não sei se
tem no Android Samsung tem não dii eu
acho que tem no Android porque tem o no
o app de mail agora tem as categorias do
Gmail é cara eu tô brincando aqui mas é
porque ti eu olho para essas melhorias
do iOS assim e eu sinto falta e eu já
falei isso em outra outro podcast que a
gente fala sobre anúncios da época eu
sinto falta quando os anúncios do iOS
eram coisas [__] muito de que iam de
fato fazer as pessoas olharem de outra
forma paraas interfaces e interações
assim de o sistema operacional de
celular sabe eu acho que é a para
correndo atrás e fazendo do jeito dela
tipo é fala faz do jeito que funciona
ali no iOS e é isso mas novo novo legal
PR caramba bom então acho que é isso aí
depois eu vou eu mando uns uns updates
aqui de algum do que que eu testei já e
qual que é o próximo watchos watchos que
também aqui eu já baixei e eu nem dei o
play ainda que eu quero fazer o tour que
ele agora atualizou e quer fazer o tour
eu vou então vou gravar o tour aqui
depois eu mando bota lá prod Arena no
Instagram da PR carena vai est lá mas
cara Eu particularmente gostei muito dos
updates do watch e vou falar aqui o
porquê eu sou um pseudo atleta né você é
mais atleta que muita gente é é ano
passado eu fiquei nos 12% do strava que
mais se exercitou cara Mas enfim e eu
uso como eu falei eu uso o o ecossistema
da Apple né então eu tenho o Apple watch
e eu pô ligo muito para essa coisa anoto
acompanho muito essas coisas de sono de
pô Como que tá o treino e tudo mais e
hoje eu tenho um app da que eu uso para
me ajudar nisso que é o Training pixs lá
que no último update da Apple foi muito
bom porque ele conseguiu já conectar com
as coisas do do Apple watch que antes
não era possível então assim você tinha
que se você tem um treinador ele
literalmente comandava o treino Você
tinha que ir lá e ajustar no Apple watch
lá manualmente agora já não precisa
fazer isso só que agora eles fizeram
algumas outras coisas que também podem
meio que matar o Training picks que é o
app que eu uso que já foi inclusive o
app da semana
e algumas pessoas que eu conheço falei
aqui com o Henrique falei com o o Fábio
falaram que o o Garmin já tem algumas
coisas que eles lançaram aqui o Garmin e
outros mas
e mais um exato mas como eu uso isso pô
para mim foi ótimo eles lançaram o
Training load lá que é meio que para
você calcular Como que tá as métricas se
você tá muito acima ou muito abaixo para
calcular seja percurso evitar problema
de exaustão coisas do tipo e ter mais
insights sobre seus treinos também poder
falar Ah pô esse treino de hoje eu me
senti muito cansado e aí pô você meio
que preparar ali os próxim ajudar a
preparar os próximos treinos eu acho que
isso vai est bem integrado com o fitness
mais pra frente também né o fitness no
último lançamento já teve um update
disso né de você poder mandar seu montar
seu personal training lá então eu acho
que vai ter mais coisas aí por vir eles
também lançaram um app novo né que é o o
vitals Pô para você cara ver como que tá
seu estatus de saúde diário mesmo
métricas de saúde mais importantes mais
rápido sabendo como que tá se você tá a
cimma ou você tá abaixo e te dá mais
insumos do que que você fazer e tal
então eu gostei gostei disso E aí as
outras coisas que eles lançaram um o
Double Tap agora pode pode estar para
mais algumas ações também então isso é o
que a gente até tinha falado né quando
vai ter isso então eu também acho que
eles foram rápidos com isso mais uma vez
quando a gente diz rápidos aqui é
rápidos baseado em como a Apple lança as
coisas velocidade Apple né velocidade
padrão é exato e uma outra coisa também
que é simples mas que cara o caso de uso
que eles mostraram já ganhou que é o
Live activities também no Apple watch
para quem usa iOS a iPhone e tudo mais o
Live activities é
basicamente você não precisa estar com o
app aberto lá para ele mostrar alguma
coisa sei lá o Uber tá tá chegando ele
te fala quantos minutos o Uber tá e
mostra a placa assim e aí pô por mais
que legal você ainda precisava pegar seu
celular para olhar a placa agora pô não
você vai olhar direto no device o iFood
também né quando foi um dos primeiros
casos aí aqui do Brasil e tal você saber
se tá Qual o estatus do seu pedido se já
tá no caminho então de novo coisa
simples mas que mais uma vez vai tirar a
minha necessidade de ter que de fato
pegar o celular para ver um aparado que
eu posso ver no relógio justo acho que
foi isso watchos tá aí esse esse eu
tenho poucas opiniões esse eu acho que é
o único produto aí da época eu nunca fui
usuário então
ai iped os esse eu o seu usuário que que
a gente teve o o Highlight do iPad os é
o app de calculadora né agora tem
calculadora no
iPad pô não mas ficou legal os negócio
lá velho [__] fazer as contas lá pô pra
galera que estuda nunca mais que tá no
colégio se tiver um iPad já tem seu
professor ali Real Time é e eu acho que
é de novo trazer pro dia trazer pra mão
das massas coisas que já existem em
outros lugares então tipo cara você
poderia fazer isso no chat APT mesmo por
exemplo tá ligado tirar uma foto ali só
que cara você tá com sua Apple pencil
ali fez cara você poderia fazer isso num
off Alfa da vida que é para um cara
muito mais avançado ali mas não agora
você abre o app da calculadora você faz
a sua conta ali e não só e não só no app
calculadora né Você pode integrar ele no
Notes direto também pode fazer no Notes
e outra parada que eu achei isso eu
achei muito legal que é o Smart script
que é você ele corrige por exemplo
quando você escreve você tá escrevendo
lá no no teclado ele te dá a palavra lá
para você corrigir mas quando você tá
escrevendo né escrevendo escrevendo de
verdade escrevendo escrevendo de verdade
ele não não fazia isso e agora ele faz E
aí quando ele corrige ele corrige com a
sua grafia tá ligado isso é bem da hora
isso é bem um uso isso eu achei muito
legal é isso é bem um uso de machine
learning ali que tipo cara o texto
escrito ali né comal Apple pensa é uma
imagem então o que que ele tá fazendo
ele provavelmente tá pegando aquela
imagem transformando em texto depois
transformando Aquilo em imagem de volta
e aplicando um estilo específico né
então cara super super legal é E aí
outras coisinhas também que eles
lançaram Você tem o você pode customizar
ali a a Tab bar né para adicionar itens
com relação a aquilo e o remote control
também isso é legal porque você você
controlar o iPad da da sua avó lá o team
vier é o Team View pro iPad né Eu acho
bom Exatamente esse caso de uso aí que
você falou mano às vezes eu passo isso
às vezes com o meu pai ou com a minha
mãe de tipo ah precisa dar uma
assistência ali no celular no computador
e pô um remote control assim bem feito
né pois de um exemplo você pode apontar
pra pessoa tipo clica aqui tá ligado
ajuda a ensinar então isso eu acho acho
bem legal acho que o iPad os continua
com o mesmo problema que a galera vem
falando principalmente pros iPad pro
acho que ele tá meio solto nas linhas da
Apple né Tipo o iPad ele não é um Mac
ele
não carece ele quem o é muito difícil
achar o uso pro do iPad dos pros né
então mas isso aí cara quando eles
começaram a falar do iPad os uma coisa
que eu achei interessante foi que eles
não porque o Ipad os agora tem os os
devices complementares a nova Apple
pencil o Magic keyboard não sei o qu que
eu fiquei me questionando assim será que
já é uma discussão n que tem há bastante
tempo assim que algum momento vai ter
esse merge do do Ipad com o Mac e até
agora é e agora aproveitando já vamos
engatar então no no ma ma eu tenho
muitas opiniões sobre é
ixe Maria cara Mac Putz velho sabe o que
que foi o Mac essa atualização do Mac
alguém lá na Apple virou assim e falou
cara vamos olhar que que o Windows faz e
vamos
copiar foi isso velho eles pegaram você
é um cara não sou eu falei isso eu uso
Mac todo dia e eu falo sem rismo nenhum
o Windows é um sistema operacional muito
superior ao macos velho muito superior
em várias coisas assim e eu acho que o
Mac agora trouxe coisas que [__]
funcionam muito bem no Windows e e [__]
vai funcionar agora no me para mim a
primeira parada mais boa velho
gerenciamento de janela [__] velho
você conseguir fazer um gerenciamento de
janela decente no os sem precisar de um
magnet do outro app que eu uso lá que
não lembro que como é que é também mas
[__] velho dá dá raiva gerenciar janela
no Mac velho isso aí eu confesso que eu
vou usar muito cara porque eu já já
monto meu desktop é desse jeito sabe e
agora mais ainda mas enfim falando de
updates aqui eles lançaram o novo os né
o novo Mac OS que vai chamar secoia mas
assim para mim a funcionalidade matadora
é o espelhamento do iPhone Cara eu
fiquei chocado que não existia no Mac
não então existia para desenvolvedor
então eu fiquei chocado que não existia
pras pessoas tipo a isso aí de novo e
agora eles liberar existe no Windows H
algum eu não sei se é no Windows com
todas as marcas Tá mas entre o Windows e
a Samsung já existe tipo há anos o
vincular no celular vincular o celular
ali então F chocado é isso agora né você
não vai precisar você pode olhar lá seu
Instagram suas coisas na tela lá
minimiza lá e pode fazer no desktop
mesmo no seu se você tiver o Mac ali
também e tal outras coisas né também
você vai ter as notificações é do dos do
iOS lá e outra né você não não vai só
espelhar o seu iPhone você pode
literalmente usar os aplicativos um
negócio que ele faz por exemplo tava
tava no vídeo que eu nunca testei no
Windows para ver se dá para fazer por
exemplo é arrastar um aplicativo do Mac
pra tela do iPhone ali por exemplo texto
Sei lá uma imagem alguma coisa assim
isso eu nunca testei para ver se dá para
dá para fazer no Windows É pô para quem
usa por exemplo eu uso muito o canva né
para fazer as as edições de coisas para
para prot Karen e tal só que é isso Eu
sempre fico fazendo no desktop jogo por
airdrop pro celular pô e agora eu já vou
fazer direto no no aplicativo do canvar
no celular mas no computador para tirar
os prints mandar as paradas tal eu acho
que vai você vai ser legal uso muito
prático disso mano para produto testar
app que às vezes você tá testando o app
que você trabalha e tal aí você tem que
ficar com o celular ali Tipo na mão para
fazer Às vez o celular tá carregando num
outro lugar e tal cara o screen share é
muito prático para isso se você faz no
computador com a tela do celular né
então você faz tudo por ali é é bom
inclusive quando você tem que dar um
screens share numa reunião às vezes você
quer dar um screen do que você tá
fazendo no celular e você consegue
compartilhar falando tudo isso no
Windows né não sei como é que vai
funcionar no Mac mas no Windows funciona
desse jeito é [__] também coisa legal
também lançou eles também lançaram o
passwords Né o aplicativo para senhas aí
já vai matar o One passw e vários os
outros aí é Eles falaram que vai
funcionar no Windows eu não lembro se
eles falaram que vai funcionar no
Android né para mim acho que a parada
principal do One password é que ele é
funciona em todas as plataformas né
então ele é é igual Dropbox tipo você
não fica preso a um a um coisa e eu vi
inclusive pessoas já falando no Twitter
problema de segurança em relação a isso
como tipo um ataque de sim Swap que é um
um problema para outras coisas até de
tomarem controle do seu sim como isso
poderia fazer você perder acesso à suas
senhas também então acho que é algo para
ficar para ficar ligado Uhum E é isso
também teve a a parceria lá com a ubsoft
né games no Mac não não vai né velho e
você não vai você que é você que é Gamer
aí seu nerdola Apple Hater aí a a posse
fosse as sei lá qualquer outra falando
de ah nossa agora vai ter as coisas de
game aqui você ia achar legal aí agora
cara é eu eu gostaria legitimamente de
ver a Apple se tornando numa
plataforma que é uma opção para quem
quer jogar porque principalmente velho
cara são notebooks caros né hoje Se você
pegar comprar um Mac no Brasil é um é um
aparelho caro e que você pô tá abrindo
mão de uma parada que às vezes você
gosta tipo e de videogame por exemplo
Então hoje você vai comprar um você quer
comprar um notebook você vai olhar para
um Mac ou para um um notebook bom Gamer
cara você tá literalmente falando pô eu
quero jogar ou eu não quero jogar porque
por mais que a Apple faça coisa ainda
não tem toda a biblioteca Teca é não tá
pronto para isso então seria muito [__]
viver num mundo onde cara porque o
hardware dos macbooks é incomparável é
muito bom assim então [__] se se tornam
máquinas também factíveis para jogar
Triple a e tal [__] do cara inclusive
num no chips M1 eu tive algumas boas
experiências com jogos assim mas nada
pesado assim então joguei para caramba
Horizon Chase por exemplo porque era um
jogo que é relativamente leve ali mas
então eu torço para que para que sim a
indústria dos Games também tá num
momento difícil velho então não dá para
saber a hora que a Apple tá resolvendo
investir na indústria dos games e a hora
que a indústria dos Games tá tipo em
decadência que timing tá bom bom do
macos É isso aí e que que tem para
encerrar ó áudio e casa esse segmento
ele é quase perdido
Exatamente é o segmento case vídeo case
vídeo exato
É cara mas eu achei legal lá o lance de
responder balançando a cabeça já mas é é
engraçado já é estran as pessoas falarem
hoje em dia já é muito comum você ver as
pessoas lá com fone falando etc mas aí
agora vai começar a balançar a cabeça
mexer música tá ligado fica batendo
cabeça assim ouvindo lo é e isso vai de
encro também as as várias notícias aí
das patentes novas da Apple com relação
aos airpods né então pode ser que também
já é um Prelúdio aí do que dos próximos
lanamentos Eu senti falta de mais coisa
de airpod com a sir nova eu esperava que
eles trouxessem mais eu acho que a gente
até comentou aqui no programa que eu ia
achar [__] quando AES fizessem isso e
tal Eu senti falta disso na hora que
entrou nessa sessão eu falei [__] agora
os caras vão botar para [__] airpod
coar não sei qu é não foi mas assim pô o
negócio lá do do voice isolation se
realmente for igual eles mostraram lá
porque assim a Apple é diferente um
pouco do Google né em termos disso assim
quando ela mostra um negócio ali quando
vai paraa prod é muito muito similar
mesmo ao contrário é então assim cara o
voice isolation só para dar um contexto
para quem não assistiu literalmente eles
mostram um vídeo de uma pessoa na rua
tão cheio de barulho e tudo mais e
mostra ela falando com a outra pessoa e
aí corta para essa outra pessoa e aí é
lá Desculpa pelo pelo barulho aqui só
que assim tá sem barulho
nenhum então pô isso isso é louco vamos
ver mas uma e também eles lançaram api
né Para você também poder colocar o
voice isolation lá principalmente pra
games e tudo mais então acho que o
Google Meet Google Meet Zoom essa esse
que tem que usar velho é só que eu
fiquei uma parada que eu fiquei muito na
dúvida é se essas coisas vão ser só pro
airpod pro porque e não pro Max porque
todos os demos lá que eles mostraram era
no pro só que o Max pô é o é o Max né é
o mais caro é o que tem mais parada e
que deveria ter esses essas coisas
também é que eu acho que o assim o pro
Com certeza ele tem um volume de venda
maior do que o Max né Muito
provavelmente e eu não sei aí eu não
lembro mesmo né porque o último pro que
eles anunciaram tinham lá os chips
também né o o chip qualquer coisa da
Apple ah não lembro qual era e tal que
ajudava a fazer essas coisas e aí eu não
sei se o Max tinha eu acho que não eu
acho que é um negócio então pode ser
isso tá ligado Tipo é processamento on
device também ali né então Eh pode ser
que seja isso é veremos E aí né Do a
gente falou do cas vídeo aqui falando de
vídeo falaram lá da Apple TV e tals que
eles colocaram a parada que já tem no
prime vídeo há milhares de anos né que é
o que é oay lá que é eles deram o nome
de Insight basicamente é você saber qual
a música que tá tocando cois Quem é o
ator co fico puto de todos os streamers
não terem isso mano porque
[__] todo mundo já passou pela
experiência de tá vendo um filme série
aparece um ator e fala assim [__]
esse cara é aquele cara que fez aquilo
em outro filme aí você vai
lá então é que mais cara um negócio que
eu achei da hora que é uma reclamação
minha também constante os filmes hoje em
dia e séries eles você tá lá vendo aí as
pessoas começam a falar aí tá baixinho
aí você vai lá e aumenta o volume aí
para de falar entra uma música aí vai
estourando meu amigo aí vem a música
porrad Dona não sei que aí você tem que
correr para baixar e a eí eles Pelo que
eu entendi né eles vão fazer uma parada
de automaticamente um quando a voz tiver
mais baixa fazera melhoria de voz da
galera e também mostrar legendas
automáticas nesses cenários assim deve
ser algo que dá para você ligar e
desligar e tal cara que eu achei muito
da hora porque esse é um problema real
existem textos na internet de tipo
gigantes falando sobre essa tendência no
cinema nos últimos anos é em relação a
isso e cara um problema real do dia a
dia que você não sei que a gente sofre E
aí eles vão resolver isso então isso
achei legal eu não entendi se é só na
Apple TV aparelho se é só na Apple TV no
Apple TV Plus e então eu fiquei nessa
dúvida assim eu acho que deve ser no
Apple TV Plus eu acho que não deve ter a
ver com aparelho assim porque me parece
uma coisa mais de software ali mas achei
achei da hora e aí para terminar assim
como eu falei que a abertura foi muito
legal pô eu acho muito maneiro não é só
Apple que faz mas todo mundo que faz
então Palmas aqui para quem fica aqui um
umas Palmas especiais para quem faz
essas montagens de tipo uma série
falando com a outra tá ligado [__] é
muito maneiro cara eu eu me amarro pô é
muito [__] isso a série fala com outra
nada a ver e pá parece que é uma
conversa [__] é muito Man o editor do
Boston Celtics não sei se já viu os
vídeos do Boston Celtics no
Twitter os Car [__] inclusive o Celtic
está passando o carro né no no no Luca
Don seus seus
comparas exato É isso com isso a gente
encerra o evento
wwdc Pois é né [__] agora que era a
sacada de eu falar o morfine e falar que
eu você pai verdade se você fosse o
Steve Jobs tá vendo É pois é mas não sou
né cara ó para arrebatar tivesse falar
uma coisa que você achou muito da hora
do evento que que foi é as coisas do
watchos o Apple intelligence não não
vale né tipo naturalmente ele é parada
Mas então vale pô eu gostei é não Então
tá se você falar alguma coisa específica
do Apple intelligence não pode ser o
Apple intelligence inteiro Tá bom então
então vai ser isso vai ser o o watchos e
o segundo vai ser as coisas relacionadas
a imagens legal legal
e e você gerenciamento de janela do mac
para mim é [__] [__] Ô imagina
imagina o ook escutando esse episódios
que fala [__] mano a gente gastou não
sei quantos Milhão para fazer só essa
apresentação aqui quant milhão aqui de
Payday e tal e os caras me fala que o
gerenciamento de janela É a coisa é a
coisa a coisa que Vai facilitar mais a
minha vida se um dia a gente fosse
ganhar um destaque na Apple depois que
eu tim Cook escutar esse episódio aqui
nunca mais a gente vai ser né mas enfim
a só olhar o que o Windows fazim é é com
isso a gente encerra o programa de hoje
também pois é é isso então recadinhos da
paróquia de sempre sigam lá a gente de
cinco estrelas aí no lugar que você mais
gosta de ouvir se não tiver estrela pode
dar joinha deu o que for aí é importante
é engajar
E compartilhe o podcast então se você
acha que alguém pode curtir esse papo
que a gente bateu aqui precisa se
atualizar sobre o que rolou aí no Apple
event que ouv um podcast sobre isso
manda para essa pessoa e segue nós nas
redes né @x @ur Close com k @arena e
semana que vem tem mais é isso e esse
episódio né que é especial aqui né
episódio 40 cheio das novidades é o nome
desse Episódio vai ser wwdc 2024 e one
more
thing [__] caraca você tá criativo cara
é E aí faz nos últimos episódios né a
galera tem postado pra caramba a da onde
que tá escutando pá então continuem a
gente deu mole Aqui de não falar no
início do episódio mas manda lá
compartilha aí esse episódio da onde o
Episódio 40 de onde você tá escutando o
as novidades e one more fing ó e já vai
ficar aqui também a enquete do programa
de hoje votem lá no Spotify que é qual
das Qual das coisas que foram
apresentadas você curtiu mais a gente
vai botar aí as opções Vision S iOS nu
Apple intelligence mas diz pra gente o
que que vocês se interessaram mais aí
dessa apresentação da Apple e no próximo
episódio a gente divulga o resultado
Exatamente é isso valeu valeu